hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the rage
okay we've got a box up here that won't
go down but that's not gonna stop me
because I'm gonna continue somewhere
somewhere there has to be the answer to
my problems which I don't really know
what the deal is but this box is not
gonna beat me
hello ah oh there we go okay I just
needed a heavy or something oh cool I
got a secret key how secretive could it
be hahahahaha ah ah very secretive it's
to the main entrance hmm okay so I need
to go to the main entrance of the prison
which I imagine is over right here okay
cool
hi buddy hey are you doing okay what you
doing there
cut poof Oh key dokey oh that was weird
why might I ask why uh I going in there
alright I'll go in there ah yay loading
another level did I miss something cuz
it was another door right over there but
I was so tempted to walk right into the
iron maiden which is probably a bad sign
for my sanity
hello this is different where am I now
okay hahahahaha what's going on here
excuse me sorry mr. shovel OOP today I
went I again went to the graveyard
master needed a new material for his
experiments a pair of limbs called
bodies typical job together paragraphs
collected all in a bag today the [ __ ]
were pretty quiet too quiet strange at
least it's not too quiet right now it's
are actually quite loud with all the
moaning and what is that is that a body
wiser
why we're doing we're doing up there are
you done
douche hello are you okay sir do you
need any assistance no I go foo yourself
um God body am i collecting stuff is
this what I'm doing is this this is my
job here oil whoa body parts pear limbs
blah blah blah I got one hey I see you
up there
let's see don't see anything else give
me Oh more oil I love it and why is -
somebody bury a piggy oh hello
no note okay what was that among the
trees I saw the outlines of a creature
no it was not like our pets it probably
it seemed to me a bag is full the Master
will be pleased the grammar
it hurts my brain oh uh so anyway um I
don't know what else to find here kinda
just wandering around trying to do with
something or other hopefully there'll be
a bit more oil in one of these graves
maybe maybe poop no just a dead guy
naked dead guy does everyone bury their
dead naked is that just like a regular
thing
I don't want to know don't answer that
hello who are you
I'm tanzanite okay hey
I'm dancing on Your Grave I don't care
who you are not a lot okay this one's
got a blood stain on it
I can't even open this one ah I'm
trapped
okay well what the hell uh what's uh
going on here ah it's the deal you yeah
yeah yeah okay dead body naked dead body
lovely think you could get like some
other than a naked dead body why is this
one poisoned all right I don't know I
don't know what's going on I don't know
what it wants from me I don't even know
where my Iron Maiden went let me go back
in the iron maiden I don't want to be
here anymore send me back come back yeah
there's no place like home
hello damn it okay there's got to be
something in the graveyard that I'm
supposed to find but where it is is a
mystery to me don't think that it would
be this guy because it's like the only
different grave here and I was dancing
on it I was uh maybe that trick or
something but no he'd get angry rise up
out of his grave why is this one blood
stained why why are you up on the
mountaintops hello hello hello hi there
are you doing good you look good he's
been doing those trunk rotations okay so
anyway this dead guy is here but I can't
find a way beyond the fence so I don't
really a little look I don't really know
what I'm supposed to do I don't know
what I'm supposed to do I'm at a loss I
don't know
I don't care all I want to do is get
back so that I can go someplace else
ah yeah I'm Anna oh did I break the game
oh lordy I think I might have ah I don't
think I'm gonna be here I don't think I
was supposed to be able to get over here
my god
ah I broke the game again oh whoops
haha push the negative oh it's time
naked push the dead body uh-huh
push it push it that body push your dead
body
you having fun buddy yeah I'm fine we
okay I'm not sweating I don't think I'm
supposed to be here I definitely don't
think that this was for me how you early
you ugly
okay so now that I have officially
broken the game and have gone where I'm
definitely not supposed to be I am going
to go kill myself somehow someway
seriously I've done a bad thing I've
done a real bad thing sorry sorry
everybody I'm just trying to see what
the extent of this area is where I could
possibly go I'm just more curious rather
than anything
excuse me we're going exploring anything
for me anything at all hello hello hello
hello just jumping along can I make it
up on top of that mountain ah yeah yeah
yeah yes yes ah ha ha ah ah yeah yeah I
hey girl
I'll kill you I'll kill your [ __ ] oh oh
that's not even oh that's not your ding
dong and what is that
that's weird you're weird here you get
pushed off the mountain Jimmy
pardon me goodbye forever go go to hell
and die okay fine you stay there you
stay there ah ah this is not supposed to
be happening
oh no I've already happening ah hang on
rajab I'm having too much fun anyway so
let's see let's go make it to the other
guys we pay everyone a visit here in
la-la land la la graveyard Edlund hello
oh dammit dammit am I going to die or am
I just folly infinitily oh the he'll
kill me
that a let's do much fun ah piss I'm
back here okay so apparently I gotta
find some maybe I gotta take the shovel
and dig up some graves I don't know oh
no I don't care the one mark with a star
nothing here for me it's all just a
bunch of crap Oh what is that
wait I didn't see this one before hey
well I mean it's got a weird symbol on
it can I dig it out
maybe yeah yeah ah come on come on come
on no all right fine then all the music
has stopped too
so now I'm just sitting here in silence
all right probably wasted all my oil
didn't I help okay so I'm a total idiot
and have wasted so much time so much
time that I am now unable to continue my
journey and once again I have no idea
where I'm supposed to go the obvious
answer is not outside of the game I piss
this vine love about a vine there's a
dead body there I'm just bogged down by
this gigantic Tour's oh I can't carry
maybe I gotta like dump it in something
here take that body in there no that
didn't work let me put it in the iron
maiden so I can get out of here and
aggravate the manure
dupa dupa nope okay I only just get in
again wow what the hell and I'm very
upset I am very very upset I cannot I
couldn't even get out I could break the
game before I found the real exit how
messed up is that
I found a wait what's this stick in the
ground why it's glowing aha
what wha-at weird-ass word okay me that
was that was [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] okay
hello where am i oh I'm in a coffin oh I
am inside a coffin this is probably not
good hello okay hahahahaha ass messed up
man
okay that took way longer than it should
have
I don't know how I missed that it was it
well it was pretty easy to miss let's be
honest but I mean it had this very
slight glow to it blah blah blah blah
okay don't bother him he's having a
private moment let's just walk away from
that from that walk away damnit okay
let's go say hi to the floating naked
dead guy I'm floating naked that guy you
want to be zap no it didn't do nothing
fine whatever you get a crowbar to the
back of the skull that's what you get
that's what you get
ah I'm touching your bot oh he touched
the butt hello hello okay alright you
just be there you float you float on
free bird
is there another button that I need to
press in another room maybe no yes maybe
so alright let's stop staring who what
the hell I don't I go ah I didn't before
haha whoa what uh hell hahahaha what I
don't even know what alrighty then let's
crowbar up these uh this one here cannot
use this item this way then let's hide
the one with the blood stain on
ah he's right there ah Oh piss I told
them why I'm so naked they're so very
naked they're so naked they're so naked
and they're quick to all they're gonna
give me I gotta give all they walk so
weird oh ah so weird yeah where they
come from I know I said jumped on the
other side of the fence oh that was
weird okay
goody goody gumdrops
I don't know hey look at another real
red glow or is that the same one from
before
maybe this green glow no red glow is
this actually doing it for I don't know
seriously you're weird and those
monsters were weirder but apparently I
can't use the crowbar get this open okay
oh boy I don't know maybe I disturbed
some graves and those were zombies very
naked zombies oh god this game this game
haha still don't know what a great evil
has to do with any of this oh good oh
good oh thank goodness
I'm out of there I think I was supposed
to run for the exit immediately
posthaste that was a trip that was not
worth taking good golly goodness golly
Grace's Jean jiminy willikers okay
you're still creepy but anyway I got a
crowbar goody gumdrops
I guess that's great so I'm gonna cut it
here so thank you all so much for
watching clicking in the taste of more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you
in the next video
Oh
Hey
everything seems to be going
so far nothing great
we